president Trump's lawyer rudy guiliani
is fighting back against reports that
mr. trump's former fixer that's michael
cohen may cooperate with special counsel
robert muller cohen is getting ready to
hire new lawyers in the federal
investigation of his business deals and
that's prompting speculation that he may
be ready to provide evidence about the
president Paula Reid is also at the
White House and joins us now with more
on this story Paula good morning good
morning
CBS News has learned that Michael Cohen
has not entered into any plea deal
despite this speculation prompted by
those changes to his legal team I've
been told by sources that he does expect
to be charged but he's gonna wait to see
what charges are filed before deciding
whether or not to cooperate against the
president he's not cooperating nor do we
care because President did nothing wrong
president Trump's boyar Rudy Giuliani
insisted Wednesday night that Michael
Cohen is not turning his back against
the president if he cooperates that
there's nothing he can cooperate about
with regard to the president shop the
president insisted his former fixer
won't flip tweeting in April
most people will flip sorry I didn't see
Michael doing that despite the horrible
witch hunt and the dishonest media Cohen
is currently under federal investigation
for his business dealings including the
$130,000 payment to adult film star
store McDaniels to keep quiet about an
alleged affair with President Trump
Daniel's attorney Michael avenatti
continues to express confidence in a
particular outcome Michael Cohen is
going to be indicted and he's going to
attempt to flip on the present I'll do
anything to protect mr. Trump Cohen's
loyalty is being put to the test as
investigators continue to comb through
the evidence seized from his home hotel
room and office in a dramatic FBI raid
back in April sources familiar with that
evidence say Cohen is likely to
eventually face charges related to
campaign finance violations and bank
fraud but if he gets a pardon on federal
charges he could still be charged at the
state level those charges cannot be
pardoned but just last week President
Trump pushed back on the notion that
Cohen will eventually even need one
there's nothing Department it's far too
early to be it is far too early to be
thinking about it law enforcement
sources say Cohen is not
to be arrested anytime soon but of
course as a member of the president's
inner circle for so long it would be an
incredibly valuable witness for federal
investigators examining any connections
between Russia and the 2016 Trump
campaign Nora
all right Paula thank you so much